this program some video and audio
portions of which were pre-recorded is
brought to you in living color on NBC
live the 47th Annual Academy Awards
presentation
this is the blood of the Music Center in
Los Angeles California which tonight is
a suburb appallingly since early morning
crowds have gathered in the rain to
watch the stars whoo
for the night ceremony covering the
arrivals
Fred Astaire nominated for Best
Supporting Actor tonight and Diane Ladd
nominated for Best Supporting Actress
there's part Kearney
he's nominated for best actor and
general and is Jenna in a jean blue
multi gorgeous gown
here's Duke Wayne John Wayne with a
special award to present tonight and
there is valerie perrine she's nominated
for best actress Raquel Welch she's in
the four musketeers and Jack Nicholson
he's nominated the best after this year
there's Lauren Bacall when the greatest
actresses never won an Oscar there's the
bridges family Jeff Bridges is nominated
for Best Supporting Actor
his father Boyd is behind them Jennifer
O'Neil Anna Donna looks white
floor-length Parnell great and Jack
Lemmon
ladies and gentlemen welcome to 1928
Calvin Coolidge is president the stock
market is at an all-time high and rising
cars have running boards prohibition is
still a noble experiment and there's a
chicken in every pot a few movie makers
get together and form an academy to
advance the arts and sciences of the
motion picture if you look closely
you'll recognize Douglas Fairbanks Mary
Pickford conrad nagel lb Mayer and
Cedric Gibbons they decided among many
other activities to give awards and
while they considered Scrolls plaques
certificates and medals
Cedric Gibbons doodle and came up with a
sketch that looked something like this
when Margaret Herrick an academy
executive saw the statuette made from
the sketch she said
it looks like my uncle Oscar and so on
May 16th 1929 at the Hollywood Roosevelt
Hotel the first film to receive an Oscar
was voted best picture of 1928 wings and
in 1929 Broadway melody followed by All
Quiet on the Western Front
Cimarron ran Hotel cavalcade it happened
one night mutiny on the bounty the great
Ziegfeld the life of Emile Zola you
can't take it with you
Gone with the Wind Rebecca how green was
my Valley mrs. Miniver Casablanca
going my way
the Lost Weekend the best years of our
lives
gentlemen's agreements Hamlet all the
king's men
all about II an American in Paris
the greatest show on earth
from here to eternity on the waterfront
party around the world in 80 days
the bridge on the river kwai er GG
ben-hur the apartment
Westside story Lawrence of Arabia Tom
Jones my fair lady
The Sound of Music a man for all seasons
in the heat of the night
Oliver
Midnight Cowboy
the connection the godfather last year
at the 46 annual awards the sting and
tonight the 47th ladies and gentlemen
the president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences an Academy
Award winning producer himself mr.
Walter Murray
good evening ladies and gentlemen I
speak for the more than 3,000 men and
women who make up the Academy men and
women who are as diverse in their tastes
as you our audience are as individual
filmmakers we all seek excellence in
both content and technique sometimes we
succeed in our efforts and sometimes we
don't when you disagree with us you stay
home and droves when we disagree with
you we try to pick ourselves up and
start again as an academy we also seek
excellence in judging the work of our
peers sometimes you agree with our
choices and sometimes you don't but
happily over the years we have been
together more than we have been apart
and those times have been the most
gratifying of all our show began with
brief reminders of Oscars past tonight
you will see Oscars present and tomorrow
with dedication and hope the members of
the Academy go back to work to create
the film's which will become Oscars
future choices it would only be
redundant for me to introduce our first
master of ceremonies so let's see how a
few others have done it over the years
category the selection of a master of
ceremonies for the evening this is a
role that calls for charm and grace and
wit and the nominees are Bob Hope for
which Robert Hope for grace and Leslie
towns hope for charm the special
envelope
the winner mr. Bob Hope
ladies and gentlemen welcome to suspense
ladies and gentlemen mr. Bob Hope I want
to tell you how I hope you all saved
your ticket stubs because we're awarding
the Oscars by number tonight
a distinguished American to whom all of
us owe many thanks for many memories mr.
Bob Hope our big pictures this year have
had some intriguing themes sex
persecution of dull Aryan cannibalism
we'll get those kids away from their TV
sets yet oh you've got the nicest guy in
town what he manages to get back here
ladies and gentlemen mr. Bob Hope good
evening ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to judgment at Santa Monica
ladies and gentlemen America's favorite
comedian mr. Bob Hope this is the night
devoted to one man Oscar or as he's
known around my house the fugitive
Academy welcomes the pride and gratitude
mr. Bob Hope welcome the Academy Awards
or as as it's known at my house Passover
here's everybody's friend Bob ho
anyway I hope your favorite wins tonight
although I know mine won't a very
special friend of Oscar without whom
this show would not be official it's the
Bob Hope in case of an earthquake you
will walk to the nearest exit I'll grab
the Oscars and run
thank you I finally made it I've been
waiting at the Santa Monica Auditorium
thank you very much I'd you like that
trip down memory lane I get a funny
feeling when I see some of those old
films I get a feeling I have a son I've
never met anyway welcome to the 47th
Annual Academy Awards and I'm here again
for my annual exercise in masochism
Ashley Yemen we're here at the Music
Center and will soon know if it has any
significance holding these ceremonies so
close to Chinatown
Chinatown got 11 nomination 6 from
column a and 5 from column B
there's some great pictures I think
Godfather Part 2 has an excellent chance
of winning neither mr. priced or mr.
Waterhouse have been heard from in four
days and I'm really not this fat I'm
wearing a tuxedo with a bulletproof
cummerbund who knows what'll happen if
Al Pacino doesn't win but I want to tell
it's a great crowd and all of Hollywood
is at the Music Center tonight and the
guy who's really mopping up is the
fellow who sells maps of the stars homes
two second-story men
I want to change the great night to be
inside because it's raining outside
lightning and thunder I didn't know that
Dustin Huffman was that powerful but
there's a beautiful audience it's
obvious that many of the ladies spent
the afternoon with their hairdresser
some had their hair done and I just
now there's a great crowd and the past
year saw the breakup of some highly
publicized romances Elizabeth Taylor and
Richard Burton
Sonny and Cher Henry Kissinger and Anwar
Sadat but there's a few people missing
marlon brando won't be here this year
either the Indians are holding him for
the balloon payment
now he gave him a little land with a
mortgage on it some gift that's like
getting a liver transplant from Dean
Martin
there's a great night I used to attend
these awards filled with expectation but
no more in my case expecting to be
handing in Oscars like waiting for
Elliot Janeway to buy drinks for the
house but don't get me wrong there's not
a jealous bone in my body but some of my
flab is furious is there no justice I
mean how can you give an award for best
achievement and sound
and ignore the campfire scene in blazing
Saddles
and amazing how times change Lenny Bruce
was busted for saying things that Dustin
Hoffman has been nominated for now Lenny
is full
Lenny is full of natural dialog if you
live in the lumber camp by the way
Dustin Hoffman won't be able to pick up
his Oscar if he went tonight he's gonna
have a friend pick it up for George see
Scott but it's great to be back in his
beautiful theater with his sparkling
chandeliers fraying fountains and lush
appointments you know this place has
been paid the ultimate compliment at
least three producers who walked in here
tonight speculated about a great movie
it would make destroying this place
this is the year the studio said we
don't care if it's well written is it
breakable or flammable and the towering
inferno was a most unusual disaster
movie imagine all those people being
saved without charlton heston
and everybody's so thrilled because Fred
Astaire was nominated maybe I should try
that Geritol after all oh he got it he
got it for towering inferno you know
it's easy to dance good when the floor
below you is on fire
this is the year of special effects you
know how Universal started the
earthquake they took away Peter Foxx
raincoat they even have ended sense
around a fantastic development in
scientific research that enables the
theater goer to actually experience the
tremors of an earthquake they attached
the theater to the popcorn machine and
of course with a new permissiveness on
the screen here there's come a big jump
in admission prices it now costs more to
watch than to participate
movies have become so permissive these
days things I used to be you know used
to be too young to see I'm too old to do
but thanks for the memory I just want to
tell you the next to his pictures are
going to be even more permissive have
you seen shampoo Warren Beatty plays a
hairdresser with a motorcycle and makes
love to five women in one day it's a
great Honda commercial I want to tell
you I couldn't write a commercial that
often but following the Academy Awards
tonight the winners will gather at the
Beverly Hilton for the gala victory ball
the losers will meet in the remorse room
of the Ramada Inn for a Binaca blast
there you are that's a wrap on
yesterday's news so let's start making
tomorrow's headlines
how about this set
I feel like Mickey Rooney playing for
the Lakers
the Lakers had a great year they spent
so much time in the cellar they're
growing mushrooms